as you heard during Ted's forecast the
heat isn't just impacting people and
pets but cars as well from batteries
dying to engine troubles 8 News Now
weather reporter Mary Jane bellies alive
with how to make sure our car is summer
ready Mary Jane
Kirsten I spoke with the local mechanic
who says when it's triple digits out
like this your car can overheat and
break down so by keeping your car in a
shaded area like this as well as having
tinted windows and even a sun shade that
can help your car cool down by 10
degrees
Nyla Marquez is a new driver on our
valley roads I also try not to like keep
it parked outside for too long however
she isn't new when it comes to the heat
as a Las Vegas native she knows what to
expect each summer yeah it gets really
high especially because my car inside
it's like leather so then it's like even
hotter but I I have like this um car
seat on my driver's side to keep it cool
Jose Martinez general manager at
Universal Motor Cars has already
serviced cars this week due to heat
related issues shaking for your fluids
make sure they're topped off also this
once a year you want to make sure that
you flush your radiator get neon coolant
new antifreeze over time and with heat
it becomes acidic and that's not good
for the engines and we all depend on air
conditioning the coolant system is part
of your AC system so if you're low on
cool under your car is overheating the
AC is not going to work Martinez says
while older cars are more vulnerable to
fail preventative maintenance will go a
long way in making sure your car works
new or old that's why Marquez already
had her car inspected a month ago I
think sometimes some people also they
like blast their AC up which they
shouldn't do because then it could like
break the windshield and stuff and that
can make it more costly like just roll
your windows down or just like keep the
door open for a little bit I know it's
hot and it's humid and it feels like
it's biting your skin but like it's it
the bill for the windshield will bite
you more
all good advice there and remember the
first 10 minutes your car is parked
outside inside will be 20 degrees warmer
reporting live Mary Jane beliesza 8 news
now thank you Mary Jane battery failures
can be more common in the summer months
too and typically they don't last more
than two years here in Vegas clean up
battery corrosion make sure the
battery's properly mounted also there
are usually signs when the battery is
dying so don't ignore them get it tested
right away so you don't get stranded